you've been married what 18 years yes  good for you that's like 127 in in how  celebrity years you know and then you  know of course you try to keep up you  know you gotta make it fresh pig won't  say make your wife your girlfriend you  know make your wife your girlfriend yeah  oh my girlfriend think you know what I  mean not not to the therapist yeah  anyway but you know but no but actually  you know like but it's the thing like  sexting that's the that's the thing that  the kids do you know they can they sex  they talk so I tried to do that with my  wife do that with your white 18 years  like I'm like I'm like sexting her one  day I'm like hey girl you know daddy on  the way home you know um I might wanna  dot dot dot dot you know did that yeah  yeah I just thought you had a bad memory  no no I got it I got it takes me back  pick up some bread like water splash  emoji own a couple of eggplant emoji  something like that how about water  splash and get some yeah yeah  [Music]  you